comment s'appelle la période durant
laquelle l'employeur et le salarié
peuvent rompre le contrat à tout moment
c'est gagné pour hervé et son équipe
leurs pions géant va pouvoir avancer de
quelques cases à la mission locale de
guyancourt
on joue au jeu de l'oie grandeur nature
des questions des mimes ou encore des
cartes surprise autour du thème du monde
du travail
un moyen ludique pour participer à la
semaine de l'emploi et apprendre d'une
manière bien différente qu'une classique
leçon aux classes en juin à ça nous
permet de mieux retenir en fait que en
cours parce que 1 des courses et des
corps toute la journée de mercredi des
jeunes suivis par la mission locale se
sont succédé autour du plateau et vu
l'ambiance ils ont bien accroché à ce
jeu de l'emploi c'est intéressant on
apprend des trucs qu'on connaissait pas
des trucs comme le poids des charges
patronales ou encore la durée maximum
légale du temps de travail en période de
crise on avait envie d'aborder le
l'emploi avec les jeunes de manière
différente et on voulait les aider à
apprendre des bases de l'emploi du droit
du travail des abréviations de base que
les jeunes connaissent pas forcément
on voulait les aider à les apprendre
de manière ludique aider à apprendre
pour bien s'orienter affronter le marché
du travail chaque année la mission
locale de saint quentin en yvelines
accompagne près de 3500 jeunes de 16 à
25 ans